baris johnson plans to remove remaining
covert restrictions which includes the
legal requirement to self-isolate if you
test positive for covert so does the
data bear that out well let's start by
looking at the infection survey from the
office for national statistics which
measures how much covert is in the
community and who's getting it now it
shows the two weeks up to the 5th of
february 1 in 19 people in england
tested positive that's up from 1 in 20
the week before with the prevalence
highest in younger age groups
now today the uk recorded 68
214
new cases but look at the seven day
average and cases have fallen over 22
there's another decrease in the number
of deaths
276 recorded but the seven day average
is down 16
now these numbers sound high but when
you look at excess mortality that's the
number of people dying above and beyond
what we'd see in a normal year it shows
the number of people who died in january
that's in red is almost 5 000 lower than
an average january
now another important issue is whether a
people are dying of covid or with covid
now this blue line shows the number of
coveted deaths within 28 days of a
positive test but look at the lower red
line this is the number of people who
died with covert as a main cause of
death as scientists say we simply need
more data but agree the trend is
encouraging
the headline figures are looking
optimistic the problem is of course this
new this other variant be 8.2 which is
increasing and whether how that impacts
on the future of the pandemic whether
that undermines
uh some of the gains that we've made
now one more interesting bit of data
shows around 98 of people across the uk
have antibodies which means most of us
have some sort of protection it might
not prevent you from infection or indeed
from transmitting the virus but it does
mean you're less likely to get severe
illness and that's another positive
signal as we step towards living with
covid